we're identical twins and today we're
playing never have I ever never have I
ever pretended to be my twin have dating
my boyfriend she would like go up to him
damn and I am oh yeah and I was like
pretending to be her and then like it
got close and she's like I was like no
I'm wrong
we're in the same class we're like let's
just switch with band class which we
carefully each other's instruments yeah
I play the drums and I play the
saxophone
we like sat down and like we're getting
ready for warm-up and then we like look
back at each other like okay I'll never
have I ever pretended to like or dislike
something just because my twin liked or
disliked it maybe right yeah yeah I
think it's pretty natural definite I
have I guess you picked your major based
on it McCartney was like oh we'll be
closer and they put you in the same dorm
like my mom was like you could do the
study abroad together
never have I ever pretended there was a
triplet this is kind of weird but we
pretend that we had like a triplet you
always say like I feel like we were
supposed to wait think we're a triplet
and we have like a boy the fraternal
yeah never have I ever used to pick up
my twin for my dating profile implying
that it's me I have not with a dating
profile but if you count I was getting
Benny for his birthday a fake ID and I
took a photo of me yeah and if you
showed a picture of you I'd be like oh
he actually really just liked you you
never have I ever say I'm the smarter
twin girl yeah all that fancy she says
it all the time and I never say that yes
okay because maybe you know that it's
not true don't we do that all the time I
am yeah is that this thing like never
ever
I always say I certainly did better on
the SAT never have I ever said that I'm
prettier more handsome twin I mean again
it's true but I think you're beautiful
oh you too we definitely have not we all
you know like guys will play with you
only but I go you're the prettier Tori
like okay well now I get it I don't use
way prettier here never ever ever kissed
my twin significant other
I have not we have kissed the same girl
is the same guy but you weren't dating
yeah Cher right look if they're gonna
kiss anyone else it's gonna be her make
fun it's sometimes sleeping in a film
never have I ever blamed my twin for
something I did every day you know that
don't have no no I have sorry I wish I
had not I can't even think moment it's
like always yeah I definitely sense a
moment you did it when I was like oh
that's so rude never have I ever wished
I wasn't born a child the thought of it
just it's like the best thing in the
world
I don't know how to be alone no I don't
know that sounds more like how I wish
that this person didn't exist and that's
just not the case
yeah no I haven't no and I never have I
ever had a threesome with my twin no and
people that I have know and people ask
us all the time
no you wouldn't never with you that's to
say this no I mean I wouldn't be if I
compose anything different answers not
learn much more about Jack I don't
imagine anything ever coming up
I already know everything about each
other yeah under the nose Isis I have
had had a great time today
I have South Africa Texas the hitch
[Music]